[Applaudissements]
on est en direct et l'histoire du jour
c'est Dogma et ses 8 Besson merci d'être
avec nous on dirait merci d'être là je
suis très heureux de vous voir merci de
m'avoir invité alors dogman je l'ai vu
c'est exceptionnel ça sort de moi au
cinéma c'est l'histoire alors c'est une
histoire vraie à la base c'est au départ
après il est après c'est parti voilà
mais tout début c'est quoi qui est vrai
pour noter les spectateurs non c'est un
petit garçon qui est pas très bien
traité par sa famille
c'est moi qu'on puisse dire et qui en
fait va être élevé par une meute de
chien c'est ça ils vont lui donner tout
l'amour dont il a besoin pour pour
exister pour être qu'il aimerait être
mais après ça devient un peu une fable
sur sur les 150 vies de ce petit garçon
qui va passer par c'est un peu Forrest
Gump ça va passer par tous les états et
on le suit en fait à travers toute sa
vie c'est vrai que quand j'ai vu le film
je te l'ai dit d'ailleurs après je
voulais dire après c'est vrai que je me
suis dit c'est il plus Besson pour faire
ça je me suis dit franchement faut
vraiment avoir un esprit de fou pour le
faire moi tu vois je pourrais pas faire
ça tu vois et partis sur un truc et
après c'est vrai que c'est incroyable je
quitte qu'il a vu ici le film du Vespa à
tout le monde bah pratiquement tout le
monde Gilles franchement c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre
c'est un chef parce que ça vous prend du
début à la fin vous êtes sous tension et
cette tension elle est à la fois un
grand spectacle comme vous savez le
faire et aussi intimiste l'acteur Caleb
lambris Jones c'est un rôle incroyable
c'est mieux que le Dieu le fameux Joker
il y a quelques similitudes c'est encore
mieux ils sont face à face avec la
psychiatre et incroyable toutes ces
scènes là sont extrêmement tendus votre
réalisation est fabuleuse je ne sais pas
j'ai vu tous vos films je ne sais pas si
c'est pas le meilleur et très
franchement on se régale du début à la
fin Cyril le disait un film à voir en
famille
on ne sait plus très bien si on aime les
hommes ou les chiens en le voyant mais
c'est ça qui est incroyable bravo de
savoir si bien raconter des histoires
merci
et c'est vrai qu'on a on a tout le monde
on a peur pour les chiens ouais tout le
film on se dit voilà et c'est vrai que
il y a une relation est-ce que vous avez
une relation particulière avec les
chiens
un petit enfin les animaux en général
entre le grand bleu Atlantis c'est pour
ça j'aime beaucoup les chiens mais les
poulpes les dauphins parce que les raie
manta ok très bien prochain film donc
sur les raies mantables vous avez fourni
quelques images du making of du film
regardez
que on travaille il y avait plus
compliqué avec des chiens qu'avec des
humains ça reste un animal donc quand il
a pas envie il a pas envie
alors sur le film dogman j'étais là pour
tout ce qui était doublage de cascade au
mordant c'était moi qui me faisais d'en
parler
je vais faire un passage du petit boulet
du petit chien comme ça après moi je
peux faire le chien qui rentre dans le
trou au moins lui il rentre
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est un des films les plus
importants pour vous parce que voilà je
vous dis vous avez fait son spin dernier
c'est toujours quand même voilà mais
celui-là il est important
j'ai Christophe carrière qui m'a écrit
qui me dit c'est qu'il a trouvé tu me
sais discret mais là je peux m'empêcher
dogman et la marque la résurrection d'un
grand cinéaste résurrection il est
jamais disparu
alors moi j'ai trouvé que c'était un
grand cru bessonien alors
personnellement j'ai adoré le grand bleu
Nikita Léon Subway donc du coup j'ai
allé avec aussi une appréhension quand
on aime beaucoup des des grands films
comme ça qui vous ont marqué et
franchement bah moi j'ai retrouvé tous
vos thèmes de prédilection l'enfance
malmené l'anti-héros anti-système
l'enfant aussi tabassé ravagé et malgré
tout la résilience et le côté justement
humain des animaux et l'inhumanité des
humains donc voilà évidemment j'ai adoré
ce film j'ai trouvé que c'était un film
très fort très beau visuellement une
musique extraordinaire des acteurs
extraordinaires une très belle mise en
scène j'ai vu aussi une mise en abyme
tout le temps tout le long
c'était le chien ou c'était le regarde
parce que
80 kg avec les
incroyable
abandonné mais malgré tout résilient et
qui se bat Moundir je sais que tu viens
avec parce que tu voulais absolument
rencontrer Luc Besson absolument bah moi
qui l'ai cru qu'un jour je serai en face
de vous monsieur Besson moi qui suis-je
des quartiers justement aussi de
l'immigration on vous aimez beaucoup
dans le quartier parce que vous avez été
l'un des premiers en tout cas
producteurs à mettre de la diversité dès
le début avec Yamakasi et
ma première projection presse alors
j'étais comme un enfant bien évidemment
et de ce que j'ai vu j'ai ressenti quand
même une belle âme et une âme familiale
ce que j'ai appris que c'était votre
fille qui produisait et votre femme
pardonne-moi votre femme et et bien
évidemment bah moi je suis très touché
de vous voir en face de moi en temps le
match je devrais faire la queue au
casting pour un de vos films mais j'ai
préféré être là où je suis face à vous
et je tenais à vous remercier parce que
je suis aussi de cette génération de
Léon et tout ça et merci beaucoup c'est
un vrai chef-d'oeuvre et la théorie de
Léon de Bruxelles
[Rires]
moi j'ai eu la mienne en tout cas merci
beaucoup ça me touche beaucoup vous avez
fini par me faire pleurer on n'est pas
là pour ça la dernière fois que j'ai
pleuré c'est quand je suis allé manger
chez gilberté
vous avez fait une belle surprise Luc
parce que Lili un des chiens du film est
accompagné de son dresseur ils vont
ensemble nous faire une petite
démonstration je tiens à dire que Daniel
Moreau a très peur des chiens il y a
même ceux qui
remuses t'inquiète pas il va être là
t'inquiète pas et puis tu as Gilles est
Moundir à côté de toi c'est parti
c'est un des chiens c'est un des chiens
qui a les roule pas ah oui c'est alors
comment ça se passe
avec plaisir alors on va faire un petit
démoulage
pas à côté de Daniel alors c'est quoi le
c'est quoi alors ça dans le truc voilà
alors moi je l'ai déjà fait par contre
tiens qui veulent faire quoi
[Applaudissements]
et dans le film elle est incroyable elle
est incroyable vraiment c'est un truc de
foudre super et c'est avec elle
justement qu'on a fait les scènes de
mordant
le Pendu
la main quoi tu veux essayer tu vas bien
alors
connaissance voilà bonjour Lili voilà
super voilà
c'est c'est comment dire en fait dans le
dans le dans le film pour pouvoir
travailler avec les lits c'est vraiment
sur une chaîne très équilibrée et qui
mord pas l'humain en soi on utilise un
accessoire elle est folle de cet
accessoire là c'est du jeu c'est c'est
vraiment c'est que du plaisir pour elle
d'accord ok pour elle mais pour moi
elle va me bouffer c'est que du plaisir
donc en fait tu peux sortir
maintenant
tu es sûr qu'il sort les doigts
mais le bras un peu
on fait une répétitions
[Rires]
on va le faire avec Daniel maintenant
impossible impossible
merci en tout cas merci merci
bravo merci à vous et merci beaucoup et
merci beaucoup et bravo pour le travail
que vous avez fait sur le physique c'est
vraiment apprécié de travailler avec
Monsieur Besson merci beaucoup merci
merci
[Applaudissements]
au total dans le film parce que 115
et ce garçon il est incroyable
franchement c'est un truc de fou alors
l'acteur aussi qui incarne incroyable
c'est pas un acteur qui est qui était
très connu du grand public et là
franchement je crois que c'est le film
qui va qui va le révéler il est
incroyable
j'ai une chance incroyable de le trouver
surtout et tu vois dès qu'il a lu le
script il est la première chose qui m'a
dit il m'a dit il faut six mois de
préparation et il avait raison
et la deuxième question qui m'a posé
mais est-ce que ça sera des vrais chiens
mais je pense que si je lui avais dit
c'est des chiens en digital il aurait
dit non
ça sort demain allez le voir absolument
vraiment c'est un chef-d'oeuvre vraiment
c'est un film incroyable moi j'ai qu'une
envie c'est c'est de le revoir Luc alors
j'aimerais je vais te montrer une image